alright bit of a late start to this game
recording start and here we go the Kings
gambit and this is Cypress right yes I
got my god one right okay let's see I in
this recently published book by Grand
Master John Shaw 96's analyzed as being
the best reply to the bishops gambit and
that's funky deform but exactly is the
point hmm I wonder I wonder about Knight
f6 here or queen edge fries probably not
not so great let's do that let's do that
that's interesting after d5 I go every
fiber go d5 and here I should know no I
should be able to take night XD five
should be should be excellent so I can
he can go Queenie too but I thought I
can give the check and then player 5
shouldn't this be a be good d 5 is also
hanging
chair let's let's start with the with
the check and now let's see yeah well
that's not so clear actually it's not so
clear mmm maybe queen edge force was a
bad one it very often it's bad in this
opening hmm yeah okay I need to do that
what's bit a bit annoying is that I can
all play 94 here he's got the double
check coming check chum what the heck is
going on here what did i do them
Wow now is he's got d5 coming
yeah just know this this is a this is a
relief at least I am still worse but at
least I'm not mated quickly yeah I get
rid of this pin as soon as possible
until maybe I as though maybe it's still
playable here and King and King d7 now
yeah it's not great but it's a it's it's
still it's still pray all I hope at
least maybe its radiation plane
shouldn't play Bishop g4
d 5 maybe d5 can I do that yeah I can
rookie one rookie head when I can place
his six next then move the night away
um wait wait wait wait he's got this
chick you know I cannot do this without
c6 don't think so okay can can I no no
no no not g5g five is not good let's not
do that I need to I need to regroup
night come on he has this check but I
can just go to the edge it's not not
really a problem i have the better bone
structure so it's not like he can do
whatever he pleases it's not not easy
for instance a fee yeah yeah let me
check and I just returned if i get rid
of the rooks I'm my menu in Birmingham
in perfectly acceptable shape okay also
go here the bishop is the bishop doesn't
know work with six and must play look f6
first I'm such an idiot no this is just
not believable after Luke f6 is just in
terrible shape no oh come on ah home how
my gosh you know yeah yeah Bishop d7
okay crap sorry after we have six white
is it simply in terrible shape and it
simply loses this end game ah nonsense
really nonsense and of course I wanted
to do it but Jim
you still need to need to play the move
yeah maybe manages to to drop his own
rock or something threatening g5
checkmate checkmate I'm sorry oh my god
yeah hmm well shows that you probably
should resign too early he's writing me
congrats yellow okay of course it's
lucky but before I blunder looking six
you're completely outplayed sorry about
being honest with you here look f6 and
white is basically toast in this
position what widest just was the stock
fish is not understanding the position
at all giving it this equal which is
just just not true his is got this bad
structure I mean white white shouldn't
lose probably but it's it's it's an
uphill struggle with the worst bone
structure and the night is simply the
more flexible piece I wanted to do this
and then you six but this was just yeah
just bad just just the terrible move
water here yeah very lucky at the end
okay thanks for watching